What is flow?
Flow is the experience you have on these really satisfying days...
...when you're productive, confident and operating at your full potential.
When a team is in flow it is innovative, harmonious and productive.
Being part of it improves the performance of each member.
Psychologist, Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi...
...writes that team flow is characterized by five things:...
...Clarity, knowing what's expected of you.
Centering, knowing that your teammates are interested in what you're doing.
Choice, knowing that you have options.
Commitment, a sense of trust in your team that lets you feel unselfconscious.
Challenge, increasingly complex challenges to tackle.
From revolutionary self-managed teams with no leaders...
...to virtual teams spanning the globe...
...while working around the clock to collaborate digitally,...
...new technology has opened up a wealth of possibilities...
...and put traditional limitations into retirement.
We want you to harness the power of collaboration.
Find better ways to create via technology and work smarter every day as a team,...
...stronger and more powerful than any lone ranger.